I hate DVR tell me the captain's secrets
unveil yourself to me T how it's made
contact lenses
bingo what are you doing here I what I'm
not what are you doing here I need to
find a New Yorker that Kevin left by the
bed so I can justify this whole
pro-slavery stance I backed myself into
detectives
Sarge I see that you like I came up here
to chastise Santiago
Amy this is low even for you I cannot
believe you would both violate the
please stay downstairs which was
probably posted get out of here I don't
know why we have to have this discussion
again why are you upset with me your
employees are the ones putting a damper
on the party they are acting terrible
you're the one who's been acting
terribly tonight
you've been Curt and snobby with my
guests you've been needling poor Peralta
so much you practically made him a new
suit needled him a new suit even when
we're fighting you're hilarious stop it
stop it
do not blow this for us you know I knew
this wasn't going to work it never has
we should have just gone out for dinner
to a restaurant like we do every year
why did you make me invite them I made
to invite them because I like them
they're good people Santiago are you
hiding in my bathroom with a dog that
you're definitely allergic to no
[Music]
occupied it's true what they say now
that I'm fully blind forever my other
senses are heightened
I feel the door we're at captain Holt's
house also the GPS announced it will be
pulled up hey once we're inside maybe
keep your hands to yourself alright
captain can be very particular about his
stuff stupid allergies he doesn't -
Kevin's closet he was supposed to stay
downstairs the binder was very clear
about that
oh no he's turning all the turtlenecks
into regular neck Charles you gotta help
us on it okay the key with dogs is
establishing the Alpha Chetta dwop it
pwease dwop it I'll give you anything
you want
Oh cheddar is the Alpha I didn't expect
that please please please nice job Boyle
it worked what the message Jake commit
don't worry we're gonna clean it up
everything is totally under control okay
it's okay everything's fine fires out in
this table is fragile I was gonna say
fragile nailed it
good afternoon thank you all for joining
me what we have here is a fugitive
situation our man has been on the run
for 30 minutes
also our man is a dog now I know what
some of you are thinking who cares it's
just a pet no one was thinking that you
monster good there's a test now the
average foot speed of a Corgi is 10
miles per hour which means with every
passing
and that slippery bastard gets farther
away captain Holt does not know cheddar
is missing but he's gonna find out oh
god I feel like the devil was dancing on
my chest all right according to the call
we just got on the tip line someone said
they saw it cheddar on this block I'll
head north
Jake you head west we'll be back in a
half hour great which direction should I
go what's going on
I can hear your lips moving are you guys
kissing what no Charles stop always
asking that look I'm sorry but you have
to stay in the car that's a mistake my
super senses are a tool you can't afford
to leave in the tool chest take me out
of the box
and put me on your belt I'm sorry but
you'd only slow us down
and that's exactly what cheddar wants
that's right
I'm onto your slippery little bastard
all right everyone listen up here's
where we're at bad news cheddar is still
at large and you know that slippery
little bastard is just laughing at us
cheddar come here baby
yeah oh I'm so glad to see you how did
you know he was here well cheddar was
only chewing up Kevin's stuff I figured
maybe he was acting out because he
missed Kevin but the real hero here is
the binder under cheddar subsection wok
subsection walks with Kevin we found
this special spot so you're missing
Kevin huh you're not the only one I
didn't cancel my trip because I was
worried you would burn my house down
Kevin and I are having a hard time right
now whenever we talk we fight and I'm
just afraid and just dis afraid that if
I go to Paris and we fight then
sir with all due respect that's crazy I
mean you and Kevin are the best couple I
know
and I'm sure whatever this is you can
get through it because you are the
strongest person I know I was weird I
said like multiple real things
consecutively yeah felt weird but good
are you proud of me you're ruining yep
I'm just gonna stop talking now
well I suppose I'm not gonna solve
anything by running away from me perhaps
I should go to Paris what do you think
cheddar huh oh my oh I'm sorry you had
to see that oh you know it's moments
like these that I'm grateful
we're on Gina's mobile should I place
this moonless Jupiter I pity the
childhood lies beneath this solar system
hey captain something's going on with
this heist you tell us everything you
know and we'll tell you everything we
know I'd rather not ah joke's on you we
don't know anything well good David wait
why are you sweating I'm not sweaty
I've had enough heart attacks know what
sweating looks like nuts sweat
[Music]
well if I'm sweating as you play just
because I was watching an exciting video
on the net oh really but it was a video
of an American gymnast his leotard
ripped exposing his but highly erotic
you're lying
IT just install blocker software thanks
to MA uh yes but they didn't install it
on my computer because I'm the captain
you don't look hot bother at all the me
show us the erotica gentlemen highest
truth nothing to see now if you'll
excuse me I have to grab some fresh air
[Music]
good boy cheddar
bring me that come above wait a minute
this isn't the championship cummerbund
this is some common cummerbund can you
not cheddar this is some common [ __ ]
where are you coming from why do you
care
thought you weren't hoisting I'm not I'm
just interested in your comings and
goings because I care about you as a
friend okay friend I went to the
bathroom you were gone a long time
friend
you feeling okay Fran no it was number
two and it was very intense friend
bless you she sneezed dog allergies
which means that ami took where is my
dog aren't you standing right next to
him this [ __ ]
please watch Jake Jake
idiot I know one of you took cheddar and
you did it for the sake of the heist but
if anything happens to him I will end
you I couldn't bring myself to neuter
cheddar but I will neuter you all
you